[Music]
hello
i'm alexander rose the executive
director here at long now
i'm coming to you from the interval
where i will be joined by our speaker
tonight peter lydon
to watch the pre-recorded version of his
talk with you all and answer questions
live afterwards
peter has been a long-time fellow
traveler with long now and has worked
with many futurists
authors and scientists over the past few
decades he periodically has assembled
that work
into his writings in places like wired
magazine to lay out some of those
predictions
tonight's talk is based on his latest
effort called the transformation
that puts forth some of the seismic
changes he sees defining
the next three decades and beyond
welcome peter lydon
thank you xander and it is a real honor
to be speaking here to the long now
community it's a community that i have
felt a part of for the last 25 years
i'm particularly indebted to several of
your founders
kevin expanded my understanding of
technology peter about economics and
business
steward about civilization and long-term
thinking and all three of them are
fundamentally optimists and i share the
basic worldview of all three of them
as well as their optimism and optimism
actually figures into this project it
started about two years ago
and we were just surrounded with a
despair
kind of a zeitgeist of despair in this
country and really around the world
is despair about that we will never be
able to solve the challenges of climate
change and global warming
that we'll never be able to deal with
the gross inequalities in america and
other parts of the world
that we wouldn't be able to deal with
our political polarization happening in
america and also throughout the west
and then ultimately we would never get
beyond the racial inequities and the
racial tensions that are still coursing
through the country
and people just have a fear of the
future they're just bombarded with
dystopian ideas of what the future could
bring
they can't imagine a better future ahead
to me there are so many positive
developments been happening and are
still happening here there's it just
doesn't map onto the story i see
it seems to me that there's a new
narrative of the story of our times
a positive narrative of what's actually
happening
and what's truly possible it seems like
we really need to tell a story of a much
better future that lies ahead
now one way to do this is to do what we
did
back in the nineties was to create a
positive but plausible scenario of the
future to let people kind of
see what actually that world could be
that's what we did at wired and that's
what we did
using the techniques of global business
networks foresight techniques and
scenarios
now today this process might best be
called speculative journalism
speculative journalism is not science
fiction which is just purely imagining
another future
it's also not neutral scenario planning
looking in all directions equally
but essentially it's a rigorous
journalistic process of
research and reporting to kind of
understand more deeply what lies ahead
to me the way i think of it is you start
with a positive reframe
you start to think about what are the
underappreciated positive trends out
there
what are new technologies just beginning
to scale but still kind of under the
radar
you also need to do some deep reporting
with remarkable innovators who are
looking ahead and helping invent that
future
and so this project i really had deep
long interviews with 25 key ones
many are from the long now network many
of these folks as well as others outside
this
network help me actually understand what
lies ahead in the next 30 years
so in the end at the end of last year
2020 i published a series of stories in
medium called the transformation
it tells the largely positive story
of 2020 to 2050 from the perspective of
someone
in 2100 but it's more than a story
it's the best case of what i think is
largely happening and could possibly
happen in the next 30 years
i think we're on the verge of another
technology and economic boom that could
dwarf the one we just went through
through the last 30 years
it may be not just a long boom a second
long boom two
but a societal transformation and in
fact we could be making great progress
on all four
of the era's challenges that i mentioned
beginning including like
climate change by 2100 if we have
solved climate change and when i say
solved i mean mitigated the worst
excesses and it's successfully adapted
to kind of live in a thriving way
if we get through that we actually will
probably have gone through something
that's closer to a civilizational change
the era from 1980 to
that period may be understood as
something comparable to the
enlightenment
and in many ways it might supersede it
in every way that's ultimately why i
call
this whole project the transformation to
make that direct parallel
so in this talk i'm going to make the
best case to convince you
that we're heading into a bigger long
boom than the one we've even been
through and that we're in the early
stages of
civilizational change now to start i
think we should go back to the precursor
the cover story eduard the book that
ultimately went into other languages
the long boom and in fact it's that
piece and that book that really is a
precursor to the talk i'm actually going
to be giving
today now this was a creature that mid
1990s this was done 25 years ago was
created
reported and written in 1996 and
published in 1997.
this was the beginning of the digital
revolution and the first what i would
call the first era of globalization
these two things were kind of
biting right in the mid 90s but not
fully understood
we forget that when you go back there
there was a very similar situation there
was a lot of gloom
there was a lot of fear of the future
people just could not imagine
what was lying ahead with these digital
technologies and what else
so what we had to think about back at
wired there was what's the big story
we're actually in
how could it unfold in positive ways in
the coming decades
what would that world look like in
effect we had to breathe life into
the digital global economy to be clear
it was a positive scenario one that just
focuses
mostly on the positive developments that
could happen it's not a prediction
still it's worth thinking about how did
we do and i'd argue that we were pretty
prescient
we got many of the major through lines
largely right
for example i think we pretty much
nailed the fundamental digital
technology developments at the
foundation moore's law kept doubling
remarkably steady this wasn't
necessarily going to be the case for the
mid 90s
the power of computers kept getting
better and better
that actually played out the flip side
is the connections between those
computers played out perfectly too this
was not again
inevitable but it was inexorable in fact
in 1997 there was about 50 million
people
on the internet basically one percent of
the global population today
close to 60 percent more than half the
world
if you look at u.s gdp from 1980 to 2020
it's just a steady upward climb
and particularly in the 90s it actually
just charted out
but again we weren't just talking about
america we were looking at the entire
global economy and in fact
the twin engine of this era was
globalization that integrated all these
economies and kept driving growth
in 1995 china's gdp was a mere
trillion dollars or so it ended in 2020
more than 16 trillion in the process
they pulled 800 million peasants out of
poverty
and became a superpower all projected in
our story
now for sure we got a lot wrong uh and
you know what do you expect telling a
story of the world for the next 25 years
but i'd like to focus on just a few that
are relevant to this talk
these were ones that i could learn from
going forward and try to correct for in
this new project
now storytelling trap is one i think
about it's
a story of the future is still a story
it's hard to tell a story without
details but given details about the
future lays a minefield
for the future when you come up to those
dates we had some good projections like
when a microprocessor hit
10 billion calculations 2010 but we
failed at how long it would take to get
to dealing with genetic diseases we
thought 2015.
and we ended our story with you know
humans making it to mars but of course
that was way off so it's hard to avoid
this storytelling trap
the other one's a little more
fundamental innovation by definition
can't really be predicted it starts with
an act of creativity out of someone's
head
and so much of the digital global
economy was driven by innovation you
know how do you breathe life into that
a striking example of this is laid out
in brian eno's 25th anniversary edition
of his diaries from 1995 a year with
swollen appendages
he talked about all the words that did
not exist 25 years ago
if you scan through that list it's just
remarkable when you see
how many things just happened how many
names
just appeared in the course of 25 years
now how could a speculative journalist
come up with even a fraction of these
another one
has to do with issues that are rooted in
politics
there were many times when politics just
screwed up basically screwing up the
scenario screwed up what could flow out
there were things that we did not think
about but kind of diverted huge
attention and resources like when the
terrorists hit the world trade center
and we went off to start
not one war but two or there's things
that
could have happened but politics kind of
got in the way
for example george bush defeating al
gore by a few disputed votes
in 2000. now we talked a lot about how
climate change would get addressed more
aggressively in our scenario
would president gore have done that
presumably probably
more than the oral men george bush the
lesson from all this is politics
matter which we'll get to in a minute
here later the final one
i want to mention is amara's law
attributed to stanford professor roy
amara
his quote is we overestimate the impact
of technology in the short term
and underestimate the effect in the long
run this
plays out in scenarios we need to
breathe deeply and slow down
everything takes longer than you think
so we thought the development of biotech
would
go much faster than in fact it did
and this makes sense when you think
about how government regulation might
slow that down we had all kinds of
things happening in that space
the same thing with climate change we
had alternative energy rolling out much
faster than in fact it happened and for
that matter we were much more bullish on
hydrogen fuel cells we clearly were
trapped in time
so that's the past but what about the
future what about the next year what
about this era from 2020 to 2050.
the primary way to start thinking about
that next period is to understand the
underlying tools and technology really
for any era they define what's possible
and they constrain what's not possible
so if you start out looking forward on
in technology
you realize that we might be heading
into three world historical tech booms
there's one in information technology
there's one in biotechnology and there's
one in
energy technology now one of the things
we learned in that last version of the
long boom is that you can get pretty
reliably
close to the general tech and economic
through lines
now i had some help from kevin kelly who
wrote a book called the inevitable
about how certain technologies are
inevitably going to happen
and kevin's a little more clear on
exactly what you think is going to
happen
in my case i think what i'm going to
talk about these inexorables are not
fully inevitable but rather inexorably
moving ahead they're going to be hard to
stop we could maybe channel them or
thwart them or slow them down a little
bit
but in general they're going to play out
over the next
10 to 30 years now arguably
all of these things i'm talking about
could be positive developments
there are some dangers as well but
generally positive ones from my point of
view
the first category is let's look at
information technologies
now as big a deal as the last 30 years
were
we got another 30 years to go i think of
it as infotech stage 2
and the first big thing to focus on is
universal connectivity the next 10 years
we're basically going to get the second
half of the planet online
we've got all kinds of operational
projects trying to do this
low orbit satellites like starlink from
elon musk
and we've got all kinds of things trying
to also boost up the bandwidth to get to
5g
so let's think that one through if you
really think about it
looking ahead asia still has about half
its people
are not online africa in the middle east
has about
two-thirds still not online latin
america about 40 percent to go
so a continued driver of a technology
expansion and off that an economic boom
is just
on the same mechanism that we saw play
out
in the last 30 years now think about
that for a moment
in 2000 you really only had a handful of
americans online
by 2030 you're gonna have everyone on
the planet
online now on the backs
of all those global connections is going
to come ai and so we're starting to see
now how
ai can be used it's an incredible
extension of human capabilities
but we're eventually going to get to
ubiquitous ai
we're going to have all digital data
it's going to be captured in the cloud
it's going to be accessible to everyone
at all times and
ai is going to plumb that in myriad ways
one of the ways it's going to actually
do it is
getting to natural language translation
by ai particularly this is going to be
useful with the second half of the world
coming online who are not
educated elites not able to speak a
second language
the business language of english so what
i think we're also going to see here is
a secondary effect of this connections
of what i would call
accelerated innovation innovation is
that making cross connections between
people from different perspectives
different fields different expertises
and if you start to think through the
impact of that kind of cross
fertilization not just across
ideas but across cultures across classes
all this mosh pit of cross connection is
going to happen in the next 10 years
now the flip side of this is kind of
related to a forward projection of
amera's law
it's hard to predict how humans are
going to leverage a powerful new tool
like
ai too many people are focused on the
negative possibilities
how many are factoring it into our
abilities to solve our biggest
challenges
we will need ai and i think we will
fully use
ai over the next 30 years to solve these
biggest challenges
i think it's going to end up a net
positive and to our benefit
for sure so that's infotech
then there's this whole world of
biotechnology
our genetic understanding is already
leading to big strides in human health
the mrna breakthrough that just came
through in the pandemic is just a taste
of things to come
i think we're finally ready to see
biotechnology's full
impact arguably biotech is where
infotech was in the 1990s now the
fundamental drivers of information
technologies
that drove the lost long boom have to do
with exponential drops in costs
allowing exponential rise in scale it
turns out
that the cost curve in genome sequencing
is beating moore's law at this point
in 2000 it cost two billion dollars
to crack one human genome by 2010
that cost had dropped to two million per
one human
genome today it's less than a thousand
bucks there's some limit but
ultimately you can imagine over the
course of the next decade it's going to
be super cheap if not
close to free so i think we're
underestimating how we could reinvent
healthcare
now we're still in the very early days
of crispr techniques but we're on the
road
to widespread genetic engineering and we
are
already moving beyond human health
problems into synthetic biology now this
is not just
genetic engineering but wider biological
engineering
we now are understanding how cells work
as well
as how the genome works and we're able
to apply that now
not basically to all living things so
for example we're already seeing how
it's impacting
food and ultimately starting to grip
into cell-based meat
we could be seeing close to 40 to 50
percent
of the meat we eat could actually be
cell-based meat over the course of this
period we're talking about here
and we could see truly sustainable
materials to replace let's say
the scourge of plastics that's mounting
all over
all these things in the biotech field
could help our ongoing challenge of
dealing with climate change i think we
could see a complete inversion of how we
produce things a
fundamental shift to actually grow
things with very little waste
from the bottom up then there's the
whole world of clean energy technologies
the third world of technologies to talk
about now they
are following the classic tech cost
curve down
and they're also hitting the inflection
point of scaling up
let's take solar which is the most
dramatic and it's kind of the classic
example
we needed that last era the long boom
era to drive the cost
down to compete and undermine carbon
energy it took 40 years but we're now
there
when we began the last era around 1980
it was like 76
bucks a watt for solar power last year
was down to 22 cents that's a 350 time
price decrease
and what do you know we're watching the
ramp up going on the other side as those
costs came down the scaling went up in
exponential fashion in the last decade
we're now at about 700 gigawatts
globally still a long way to go to
displaced carbon
again but remember what the scaling of
digital technology was
in the 1990s in fact if you pull back
and look back in the last 20 years you
can actually see how the installed
solar globally has risen in logarithmic
scale
granted from a very low installed base
but now the scaling itself
is driving the cost down every doubling
of the industry installed base
drives the cost down 30 to 40 percent
which keeps up the virtuous circle of
growth
the same dynamic is happening in
electric vehicles in just the last
decade the cost of battery packs for
electric cars have been driven down
to be almost fully competitive with
internal combustion
engines but if you look out for the next
decade
they're expected to drop another three
to five times
and in the next few years or so they're
expected to be cheaper than internal
combustion engines and so across the
board better
easier to maintain safer and cheaper
fuel
and so what do you know you're watching
the ramping up just
starting we're still again just in the
last decade we're starting to ramp to
about seven million electric cars
were sold globally last year again still
a long way to go
but remember the 90s and the tech ramp
up
so to sum up you have three world
historical tech booms
all three are geared to full global
markets but to really solve these big
challenges we're going to need
politics politics can and does screw
things up as we mentioned
but the flip side is that politics
matters good politics can solve problems
that's not to say that politics is
random the basic pendulum swing between
progressive
and conservative errors this back and
forth that's played out over american
history
but we watch how power shifts to more
people-based power and progressive eras
and then back to more business power
in conservative era it's how the core
values move from a more collective sense
in progressive areas
to a more individualistic sense in
conservative era we've watched this
pendulum swing over time back and forth
in fact if you go back 80 years very
similar situation to today the 1930s we
had extreme political polarization and
paralysis we had mounting authoritarian
nationalism
but that opened up a long run of a
progressive era really a 40-year
boom this was the textbook case strong
government build infrastructure spread
wealth the democrats
dominated that era but both parties work
within the context for example
nixon extended the great society as a
republican
but the end of that run in the late 70s
it was becoming outdated
out of ideas out of energy and so the
handle them swung again
and so then you watched essentially a
conservative era open up
1980 brought ronald reagan to the
presidency in about a 40-year run
of the conservative dominated time the
boomers
dominated the politics they're much more
individualistic and turned out to be
conservative
the republicans dominated but both
parties worked within
bill clinton reformed welfare for
example but again by the end of this
period the last decade
it ended up outdated out of ideas and
pretty much corrupt
so i would argue a strong case we're
entering another progressive era
this is not wishful thinking but it's
built on the inexorables
this time demographic ones these cycles
are driven by
deep demographic forces that build
ascendant coalitions
the first is a generational shift
the dominant generations of an era
largely drive the politics
generations have personalities and value
sets
that pretty much hold through life the
gi generation coming off the fdr
drove the last progressive era the
boomers coming off when
reagan ascended kind of drove the last
40 years
so what about this one that's opening up
it's going to be driven by millennials
now these millennials have much less
stake in the current society they
amassed
very little wealth in the last run and
they are much more transformative in
their thinking
think bernie sanders that's who is
behind him
but if you then add the generation z
that's those people born from 1997 to
2012
this generation of generation z is very
very similar to the value set of the
millennial generation they seem to align
very clearly in all the polling up to
now and it looks like a very little
distinguishes between the two of them
we're gonna see with those two
generations a double-barreled
power that's gonna push for more
transformative change at the same time
if you look how it plays out the boomers
are literally retiring in mass and dying
off
by 2040 the youngest boomers not oldest
are now age 75 and the oldest
they really are passed away by 2040 the
oldest millennials are just
hitting their 50s and they're pretty
much running everything the generation
behind gen z
who knows might be budding conservatives
it's not just generations there's other
inexorables too growing numbers of
people of color
immigrants tend to have higher birth
rates so in fact
america is clearly on track to be a
majority minority
population by the early 2040s this is
inexorable it's happening
then there's also the relentless
migration to cities
the superstar cities and the coasts have
been the early ones to benefit from this
but all cities even in the heartland
people are going to the cities
today only 20 of america is in rural
areas
by 2030 it's projected to be only 10
percent
people in cities correlate to being more
cosmopolitan
and more progressive think about the
politics final thing to mention is
education
college grads now are more than a third
of all americans
younger generations are more than 60
percent are in college
or have been into college education
strongly correlates to belief in science
facts climate change now how does this
play out in politics all these
demographic inexorables hit california
first
remember california was a red state it
invented modern conservatism it was the
home of ronald reagan and the tax report
but also california was the first to let
go of that conservatism
today all statewide offices are run by
democrats
this is going to play out over america
and it's already happening
particularly in states most like
california
like the southwestern united states if
you look at this 2004 map
of president bush you could see that
essentially
a lot of red states this was the high
water mark for republicans since ronald
reagan
all those southwestern states are red
if you look at the last election it just
happened with joe biden and kamala
harris the southwestern states are all
four of them are blue
just in those 16 years we went from zero
electoral votes
blue in 2004 in the southwest to all 31
blue in 2020.
we also went from only two democratic
senators
in 2004 out of that region to all eight
in 2020 and then if you look at that map
you see the state of georgia the heart
of the door old south went blue
why the same in extra bulls young people
immigrants people of color the urban
area of expanding
atlanta and the educated people in the
suburbs this
is the blue america thing going to the
heart of
red america 2. so if you think through
the politics of the 2020s it's pretty
much
going to be a blue lock on the
presidency and an increasing balance in
this
senate this is again counter to the way
people think about this now
but it's i think inexorable remember in
this election
texas was in play it's probably going to
flip blue in 2024
it has the same dynamic as all those
southwestern states
including high rates of people of color
and immigrants north carolina was in
play even south carolina was
talked about in play this time this is a
pendulum swing and is only swinging one
way
we are entering a new political era one
inexorable
is going to be reinvigorated government
we're going to go
for the general strong government
tenancy that's going to invest in
infrastructure and alike
i think we're going to see a rebalanced
economy to take on
mounting inequality young people people
of color
much of the coalition of that blue
america has been cut out of the wealth
that was engorged in the last era
and they're very attracted to
transformative policies like
bernie sanders and even beyond watch for
the traditional counterbalance to
corporations
after kind of having a free reign with
conservatives you're going to watch a
lot more kind of
regulation including in tech and i think
we're gonna actually see
that wealth inequality being pushed back
in the realm of taxation too
the levels of inequality are now back to
where they were last seen in the
beginning of the great depression
where the top one percent own in assets
as much as the bottom 90.
this was the same phenom that helped
start the last progressive era with fdr
and that kind of rolled for about 40
years and it kind of rectified things
that was reversed again in the 80s with
the conservative era
and now we're back to where we started
expect taxes to go back
to historical norms and more
who was in the streets this summer
people of color and the two younger
generations
those two generations both are about
roughly
50 50 whites and people of color
they want no part of white supremacy
they embrace diversity there's no debate
in that
so i think we're going to see in a third
shot at rectifying
racial inequities in this country truly
i think it's going to be more like the
third reconstruction
the original one coming off the civil
war the second one
in the civil rights area of the 60s i
think we're going to see a third one
the final thing has to do with climate
change
there's almost zero climate denial on
those generations or in the coalition as
a whole so we're going to see government
gear up and set
high strategy goals and standards we're
also going to see business align with
this
given their workers and customers of
these generations finally we're going to
see climate cooperation
it's going to really make a difference
now if you're really trying to talk
about solving climate change then you
got to think globally
we've been mostly talking about america
the liberal democracies the west
we have to adjust the lens to the big
picture global view as well
now we have a lot of these technologies
are inexorable and that they could scale
globally
it turns out there's other inexorables
at the global level too there's mega
trends that are
beyond tech that are quite fortuitous
they're largely
positive developments that could help us
solve
a lot of these challenges too
particularly climate change
one of them is burgeoning capital we
have the technologies but do we have the
capital to transition
our entire energy system to transition
the economy to sustainable everything
well it's about a hundred trillion
dollars in capital markets sloshing
around right now it's all looking for
productive investments
and it's actually not getting the kind
of returns it wants i think the super
tanker of global finance is going to
move this decade and there's signs that
it's happening
much faster than people think another
inexorable is
chinese superpowers china has now
at the end of their 30-year run become
truly a global super
power and we need them china
can actually move and act in ways that
the liberal democracies as of now
can't we're still debating in america
whether climate change is real
and china is just moving huge amounts of
assets
also the chinese model is much more
relevant to the developing world
they pulled 800 million peasants out of
the poverty into cities in the last 30
years
and that's something that has to happen
around the world which brings up total
urbanization
another inexorable in this last decade
the world tipped past 50 percent of the
world now in cities
it's about 55 now but it's heading to 80
by 2050. this is essentially a good
tendency for the planet
it lowers the human footprint it brings
many other positive developments like
empowering women
which lowers the number of children and
which essentially reduces population
pressures another global inexorable is
middle-class majorities just in the last
few years the world crossed another
milestone
in which we have now 50 of the people on
the planet
are middle class 3.6
billion people now this is considered
middle class in a global context these
are people who can afford maybe
something like a refrigerator or a
motorbike or have some mild security
unlike people who are really destitute
or poor
now this is not what we think of in the
west
as the middle class those would be
considered more almost rich people
in a global context now middle class
majorities in a global context
is a good thing middle class people
spend almost everything they make back
into the economy
driving economic growth middle class
people tend to be a huge stabilizing
force in society
they demand good government they're
trying to get good
learning and education things that are
good for
everybody in the long haul by 2030
it's estimated that the world will add
another 1.7
billion middle-class people to their
ranks this again is global middle-class
people to their ranks
we're going to have well over 5 billion
people
who are considered in the global middle
class
going forward beyond that point so in
summary i think we
can actually solve climate change it's
totally possible it's plausible it's
even probable i would argue
we can when i say solve it we can
mitigate the worst
that people are fearing we can adapt to
what's already in motion already baked
in
and we can create a life which many many
people the world can really thrive
a final point is that this is not just a
story
not just some imaginative sci-fi this is
a work of speculative
journalism reported and researched it's
a
positive reframe of the actual story of
our times
it's a new narrative of what's really
going on and what could well
happen i think we're beginning another
set of technology and economic long
booms
i think this is going to give us the
tools and the resources to help solve
our biggest challenges
i think this may well lead to a social
transformation
and will be seen as the early stages of
civilizational change
now the long now is one of the few
places that can hear what i'm saying
and totally track it there's few places
few communities out there that think out
30 to 80 years very few talk about
civilization
i think of the long now as a 21st
century royal society
it's driving a global conversation that
people need to hear
and it's a group that's maintaining
optimism
for the log hall i've been happy to be a
part of the long now for the last 25
years
and i'm eager to be part of it for the
next 25 years
the next generation i think the next 25
to 30 years are going to be an
extraordinary time
i think people in 300 years 500 years
a thousand years let's just say it 10
000 years
they're gonna look back on our era from
1980 to 2100.
i believe america is in one of the
biggest junctures in its history
i think the entire planet is in a world
historic
moment i think we're going to figure out
a 21st century system that works for as
many
people as possible for the long haul i
believe
we're in the transformation thank you
thank you so much peter uh that was
fantastic and i
i i'm really excited that you can join
us here
live tonight from the interval we're
able to have both of us here in the
studio although across the room
um and um so welcome thank you for
joining us
it's great to be here it's actually
interesting to watch yourself as opposed
to actually
forming it and coming off that talk so
it's interesting to watch
me uh talk to you nice
cool well i mean i think it's it's it's
especially interesting to
you know in the middle of a pandemic to
have a positive view of the future and i
think it's it's welcome and i think
you know as you and i have both
discussed there were through the roaring
20s came out of the last pandemic
and um i think it's it's important to
know that at least there is a version of
the world that can be much more positive
than the one that we're currently living
in so
i want to especially thank you for that
because i think it's it's a difficult
project to do
now um and i think we need it
um but i want to just talk a little bit
about that
in that um
you do mention this kind of storytelling
trap and um
most of these things having positive out
outcomes
of course there's going to be some
things that have negative income
outcomes or a you know a weird thing
like a pandemic or a
comet strike or who knows what it's
going to be there'll be something that
happens in the next 30 years
that um that is negative and
how do you want to address that in
context of this piece
well one of the ways i think about this
is the culture itself is just
filled with um
[Music]
all kinds of dystopian roles out in all
kinds of ways
all the disasters are going to happen i
mean any side five programs tv shows
magazine articles cover stories and mag
all the things it is we're just
bombarded with this so one of the things
i'm trying to do is overcompensate and
and you know it's a conscious choice
of trying to stress that what is getting
lost in this look ahead in the future is
essentially all these positive
developments that are inexorably kind of
going along they're kind of in the
backdrop
they don't get the same drama i mean you
know the rise of the middle class
globally the rise of you know the kind
of urbanization that's
a positive thing i mean these things are
just backdrop statistics that
occasionally surface and people miss
and so in many respects in this story
i'm just trying to focus on that knowing
full well
that there's going to be a completely
crazy bunch of things that are going to
come up here
including wild cards that'll set us back
um for sure it's going to happen and it
will happen
it's kind of i mean basically it's kind
of the one one step forward two steps
back two steps forward one step back i
mean is this that's just the way
progress happens that's the way
technology rolls out that's the way kind
of
economic booms happen we're going to go
into a crazy period of time here and
there is
absolutely going to be a lot of negative
stuff that's going to happen and there
are going to be times where we'll be
ringing our hands thinking oh my god
it's over
but i think what i'm just trying to lay
out there is what is missing
uh and largely missing certainly when i
started this project with like you
couldn't even find anybody kind of
trying to talk about the positives of
the next 10 20 30 years
i will say it's shifted differently
literally just in the last couple of
months you're starting to watch a kind
of a conventional
kind of a news way to frame that coming
off the pandemic with the pent-up
consumer demand and you're going to
watch with the
with the uh the vaccines coming together
and actually opening up
uh the economy again that you're gonna
see some kind of a boom
i think of that as relatively short term
consumer boom kind of the beginnings of
like you say the post-pandemic kind of
roaring 20s that is a
for sure true thing it is happening and
it will happen but i think what i'm
trying to get at is these deeper things
that'll keep playing out for 10 20 30
years and that we haven't
really thought through fully what it all
means i mean when
if we are going to shift even the vast
majority of our energy system on the
planet to clean energies over the course
of the next 30 years i mean just think
of the economic opportunity that
and just think about the scale of change
that's going to be needed and just think
of all the businesses and jobs and all
this kind of stuff
i mean people kind of know it at some
level and they kind of think okay yeah
somehow we got to do this but they
haven't really thought it through i
think when you do think that through and
you do think that through all these
other things these
inextricables i was telling you and see
them in synergistic kind of alignment
it really makes you think oh my god
maybe we are heading back into something
uh that is going to be quite
extraordinary
indeed well um i'm going to move over to
some questions from our feed
and then we also have one of the people
you mentioned one of our founders kevin
kelly who will be joining us
on the stream but we have one of our
other founders you mentioned stuart
brand
watching on the feed and sending a
question by text he says pete why is it
easier for people to understand and
believe a negative scenario than a
positive one
you know stuart that is a great question
i've been thinking about it for the
longest time
my basic way of thinking about it is
again with the long lens of kind of long
now thinking
um is i just think humans have been
wired from the beginning to actually
be anxious and afraid the russell in the
bushes you know it was
it was those humans that heard the
russell in the bushes and freaked out
like it was the freaking lying
that actually survived in a way that the
person that just was a little more
laddied on not worried about it and kind
of blue sky thinking oh it's nothing and
then they got you know they didn't move
on
and so i think it's it's really just in
us
it's just baked into humans of just to
actually be constantly
anxious about everything and it's been a
survival thing it's been something
that's just right there
so i think it plays into um that's one
thing i think that happens is people
start think when they think about the
future they think it's they go into it
with fear that's one thing that's
interesting
the other thing i would say is just from
the point of view of someone who's been
doing this and
as uh through wired and global business
network where i actually work with
stuart
um it's just so much easier to do
negative scenarios i mean it's just easy
to unwind anything just
blow stuff up make things bad people
turn out evil
you know it's like easy and that's why
every damn you know cheap movie b-movie
you know tv show that's barely you know
thought through it's all negative and
it's all just spins out disasters right
easy to do much harder to make a
compelling
positive scenario much harder to show
get make it exciting and engaging that
people can actually
see positive things coming together now
i think
i've been always waiting i've been kind
of proselytizing but she'd have a thing
called
a genre of movie called blue sky sci-fi
i think honestly we could actually have
a whole category of
these things where people spin out
actually positive features that
ways things work and i don't i actually
i it's just
it hasn't happened maybe there's some
just formula that just never works but
my gut feeling is particularly these
younger generations they want a can
can-do forward thinking this
could work frame as much as oh my god
we're doomed it's all going to go to
hell you know
i think i think it might have been we
might have been that was more of a
boomer thing you know maybe maybe we're
going to kind of go into a kind of more
uplifting period here where you know
people just
soon kind of see the positive stories tv
shows
books conversations whatever that's a
little more speculative for me but i
would say
easier to do and also people just are
wired to freak out and they're not wired
to actually think confidently and
thoroughly and consistently uh about the
future
that's what we need to do that's part of
the long-range thinking and i think one
of the things that uh long now has been
doing and i think one of the things
this community's been doing is trying to
structure structurally and
rigorously think forward and also often
with a positive and more optimistic
frame i think it's an instant
indispensable
thing that right this community but i
mean i think also one of the things the
ways that we create a positive future is
by envisioning negative ones and
creating the antibodies
as a way and creating the kind of the
story that we don't want to have come
true
and so that's in some way that's that's
that's one of the ways we create this
negative future so we tell that story
enough that we
we invent the things that stop it i
think that's entirely i think that's
true but i think there's just enough of
that going on that boy we need a few
more of those positive ones in there i
think i think he's gotten po
the zeitgeist of despair in this country
and in the world in the last five
three to five years has just been just
debilitating i mean i think it's just
going on too much
and we need to kind of counter and i
think we're actually are starting to see
the counter force is starting to pop up
here i think people are ready for
for a positive reframe well
i'm gonna ask uh one more kind of
question on urbanization before we jump
over to kevin kelly we have several
people asking questions about
urbanization
and i wanted to ask about it too i mean
obviously one of the biggest um
reasons we could have a reversal trend
against urbanization was something like
a pandemic and we're seeing that to some
extent
at least getting people further out to
the suburbs you know san francisco and
new york and la are kind of we're seeing
now a decrease in population which
uh you know christie from our feed
points out
um and then that and on top of that we
have these
uh connectivity trends which are
allowing people to knowledge workers at
least
uh work from more remotely um
and so i just wanted to ask you know
what is what is your take on that on
that trend both of de-urbanization
um and are there limits to the
urbanization that we currently have that
that we're going to see
uh interesting questions one that
everyone's hanging out here
my quick hit on both the two kind of
points i'd really
like to make is cities have always
emptied out in pandemics
and they've always recovered and always
come back and they've come back stronger
and bigger and
whatever for always there is something
just like i said there's something wired
in humans to kind of freak out about the
rust in the bushes there's also a
fundamental piece about social animals
particularly
ones who like uh physical intimacy it's
frankly sex and connection with people
in in a way that goes beyond the virtual
that i think is just
this inexorable pull that the cities are
going to have now that said
uh uh so i'm not counting out the the
cities on the coast and all you know san
francisco it's been told it's been dead
for how many times and it just keeps
coming back
but i do think what is interesting about
this next phase is because of the
high bandwidth connectivity and because
of the virtualization so much which by
the way is going to get even more with
virtual reality and all the stuff that's
going to go even deeper emission
of virtualizing things i do think we're
going to see a ah
a revitalization of cities in the
heartland smaller cities all through the
place i mean you're watching right now a
lot of people
frankly the superstar cities were just
getting unlivable for
for everybody i mean no one can buy
houses you couldn't move in
you know traffic around here and stuff i
mean in some ways people are just
in the bay area here where i'm in and
where you are is like finally we can
just drive around and finally we can
actually
do some things that have just been so
hard to do right yeah
talking to kids who are starting college
this year
they are pretty ready to get out of
their homes and dorm rooms and get back
to a party for sure
um all right so we're going to invite
one of our founders and one of the
people you reference in the talk kevin
kelly
who worked with you a little bit on this
piece as you were going
i will say kevin kevin i've had many
conversations with kevin and he has been
very instrumental in helping in this
project and helping
influence my thinking over the last 25
years absolutely thank you kevin so glad
to be here
you did a great talk pete i was inspired
i want to be part of that future
please let's make it happen i'm down i'm
down with it
let's do it so um
one of the questions i would have is um
what kind of reaction do you get when
you tell this
very positive story to people maybe
people who have heard only the
pessimistic
view um do they find it persuasive
can are they able to believe in it
in general are you able to convert
people
um that's an interesting question i
would say
people are are what's wrong the wrong
word wired people's their knee-jerk
reaction to it is oh that's
too positive you can't be too positive
it's
that's just not how the world works it's
not workable
uh it's it's dead end it's not a
non-starter i mean that's honestly and
there's a lot of
super smart people um who when you talk
about this it's just oh no no no no
and i think there's something weird
about that i think i think what it is is
i think
educated people intellectuals
particularly are kind of
um raised and are just surrounded by
news magazine analysis books i mean all
the kind of intellectual thing is
almost i would just put a number on it
you know eighty percent of it is somehow
negative you know
and there's a lot of people kind of
ringing their hands about the negativity
of news and stuff but when you're kind
of
in an environment like that constantly
and just it's just seeped into your
pores it's just the way you think about
everything
when someone comes around with a totally
different way that's positive and
reframed and kind of has
it's thought of as naive or it's thought
of as like uh you know
oh that can't be right or anyhow there's
just some weird thing so yeah it's a
frustrating thing i will say this
it's not just this project you got me
doing this i've been doing this for the
last 25 years i've been doing a lot of
public speaking and
i'm always positively saying it i will
say this people love
at least to go for the ride for the
hour-long talk or something
they actually like to do it because it's
so rare to do it and they're kind of
like wow
wouldn't that be cool there's a lot of
them that actually do that and so
um i don't think it's a lost cause to
push that
rock up the hill but i do think because
i think people are open to it and when
they see it
they have a thrill for it but then they
pretty much settle back into their
negative space so i think it's more like
maybe building a movement or building a
body a consistent media landscape that
has more of this i don't know it needs
it needs more
voices it needs more energy it needs
more ideas that
this and i know you've been thinking
about this too um with your protopia
thing i mean i think people
need to things to hang on to they need
to grab it they need stuff and that's
really what this project was was just
let's get something
in writing which is where in medium by
the way anyone can watch this
uh the transformation it's a series of
six stories in there um
this talk will be one and other venues
and i'm going to kind of keep pushing
this because we just need to keep
banging the drum that uh
we got to stay open to this and really
not only open to it but really engage it
seriously and think
why not i mean why isn't why isn't this
why is the narrative right now that
we're on the cusp of an amazing
era of reinvention of america amazing of
era of scaling up like to solve global
problems to
kind of harness ai and take advantage of
biological engineering and
why isn't there this kind of totally you
could amaze you can imagine a narrative
of that
it's based on the tools the rally you
can just people doing it in a million
different directions but that's not the
narrative the narrative is this
everything's screwed up everything's
gonna go wrong everything's gonna
you know ai is gonna overrule us biotech
is gonna you know we're all gonna be you
know mutants and anyhow
you know the whole story it's it's it's
a
it worries me but it's something i'm
doing my best to counter it's best sex
so um your your vision your story has a
little bit of a very global kind of
tech view the politics are very us
focused i increasingly have come to
believe
that more and more the future is going
to be decided by
non-americans the young non-americans of
the world that you
kind of hint at and um uh
do you have a sense of of their politics
um and wouldn't that be a better
audience for this talk is the young
of china and india because in a certain
sense
those are the people who are going to be
making our future
good point i know that's something that
you've always championed in and one of
the exciting things about the
connectivity that's to come
and this again kind of uh
interconnection
through language and and uh
understanding
is going to come with the potential to
do that i mean
you know right now it's hard to figure
out a way to actually communicate and
really get your
eyes uh your ideas out that way so
anyhow it is something that i
um i know that's maybe not the best way
to answer your question but
i do think uh to the extent we're going
to be able to kind of
proselytize and spread the word i think
i think what it is is for those of us in
the west here is to actually uh
help energize and help empower
essentially the folks i do think will
build the future
i'm a little worried about the china the
chinese
way i do think there's still two systems
existing right now
and although the liberal democracy
world is kind of decadent and not
working very well i'm a little
concerned about a kind of more um
authoritarian kind of
chinese version and to what extent
that's
uh i i think of it they're comparable
they're straight offs with both and i
think that's why i see them as allies in
the solving climate change thing but i
don't know
if um i don't know which is
better in the long run and i'm so i'm
still not kind of going that
as far as that so so uh maybe my last
question is um
uh i'm with you that we don't really
need to
um drum up more dystopians and negative
scenarios because
there's machines that do that already
very well
but i am interested if is if you had a
magic wand that could remove
one hurdle the biggest hurdle you see
for this
vision coming true what would that
one hurdle that you would like to see be
removed
what is the sort of the biggest headwind
against this
um half happening
wow that is an interesting one um
from the global point of view from the
from the global point of view um
if it was a magic wand if i could
literally just do a magic wand
um
to me what's missing maybe this isn't as
big enough to swing with my magic wand
that i have
but i but i think if what i think is
missing right now
is people cannot comprehend they cannot
think they cannot envision they can't
see
how a better future works in a kind of
more comprehensive way they don't
understand
how could the economy work to be more
kind of equitable and kind of
rework wealth differently and deal with
mitigating inequality
they don't understand how would we
really uh
solve climate change in the you know
reasonable time here to kind of stay
under the
kind of global warming kind of levels
that we got to worry about they don't
see
how would you rethink a more global
world that is kind of
working on a planetary scale and you
know beyond the borders of a bunch of
collection nation states i mean there's
a bunch of things that people are just
they don't get it and so they say hang
back and they
hold and they're they're their their
kind of position and they even look
backwards and say well god wouldn't it
be good if we just did it what we did in
the 20th century or
you know some people are going back all
the way to the founding fathers and
saying you know originalists you know do
what they did you know
in the 1780s like anyhow it's a backward
looking thing so i but i think what's
happening is it's hard to envision that
future it's hard to see it and if
there's some
way maybe it's different kind of media
different kind of thinking
different kind of mental tools or
something that would just
help people see more clearly rigorously
thoroughly
comprehensively what could lie ahead
i think it would energize uh people to
do
to start doing it in a way i think it's
it's right now it's
it's it's missing the missing piece is
the envisioning piece
and not into a kind of trite way of just
you know build a better
life and we're all going to be better
it's like how do do these future systems
work
how could they work can i mortgage my
future on it can i mortgage my kids
future on it can i
you know move in that direction can i
let go of my own
career and move into that career i mean
it's hard for people to see that and
that's why i think the whole field of
futurism and i think the whole field of
of kind of thinking uh systematically
about the future is so valuable and it's
so
still crude and still kind of unformed
and i think boy if i had a
magic wand some way we could just do
that with more
kind of uh christmas and and clarity
and uh to make it things more convincing
i think it would be awesome and it would
mobilize political will
and energy in new ways uh that i think
we're lost right now because we can't
make people see it and this is my little
vague way of
in this you know talk or in this series
showing one way
that if you just suspend this belief a
little bit and think about it it's just
helping people
see that through life see what's out
there
uh it's a pale attempt it's one attempt
but uh boy we need more of us doing it
that's what i would say
well there's my wine well your magic
worked on me this evening so thank you
thank you well it's always good to hear
that from you kevin i appreciate that
thank you kevin really appreciate you
joining us tonight um we're
wrapping up the q a right now we're past
the top of the hour
i will say this this talk generated more
online questions than i think any one of
our online talks
so far so you've definitely got people's
attention
um and but we have we have several
questions one from nick
uh one from michael hertz on this kind
of where does decentralization and
centralization
play out i think you know we see forces
of centralization right now
you know obviously in the big huge tech
companies like facebook
and apple and these kind of silos of
technology that are
owning google that are owning so much of
our online world
we see versions of decentralization with
uh forces like you know more open web
type sources like wikipedia winning out
over britannica
or um you know these you know craigslist
largely winning out over
you know online classifieds of other
types
and i think now we have other forces
that are kind of coming in sideways to
that like cryptocurrency
um obviously being another
decentralizing force that are
potentially an economic decentralizing
force and so i just wanted you to
if you have a chance to talk a bit about
where centralization and
decentralization both either technology
and
economics work out in this
yeah great good question um and uh
for those who asked it and yourself to
ask here's the way i'm thinking about it
is um in the relative short term
i think the forces of decentralization
are actually going to
[Music]
be where the energy is going to go um
and i think
you know the era of you know the nation
state we all look to you know
biden and his cabinet to solve
everything that that's that area is less
and less a thing that was kind of a
thing and it was a 20th century thing
more
can be less less it's more like oh
what's california doing or what's the
crypto crew you know
energizing you know some outfit in you
know whatever another country anyhow
there's
i think there is a decentralized thing i
think this also includes tech
uh i think um but here's but here's the
here's the difference so there's a
decentralizing thing that i think is
still the predominant thing
energy of where the where the air is
going to go but here's the problem and
it's an interesting switch and i spent a
lot of time thinking about this as i
talked more civilizationally we didn't
really get into that and that's part of
the talk just you can only do so much in
35 minutes
but um the ultimate challenge that's
going to happen to the planet
particularly if we try to solve climate
change in a way that's going to
work is we have to operate on a
planetary scale and it seems to me that
there's going to have to be some kind of
global
governance at some level or global
coordination
that i don't necessarily think it would
be centralized like it's going to be
some little cabal of people that runs
the global planet but there is some kind
of
another level of world historical
not centralization but coordination at a
global level that we've never seen
before that we're going to need
that's going to happen i would say
increasingly in the next 30 years but
across the century that is going to be a
thing um
but uh but anyhow and so it's this
global
reconnection at a global level beyond
the boundaries of states and
and nations and stuff that is is is an
energy that's going to take the whole
century to figure out but basically that
thing is what's also screwing up and
countering this decentralization thing
so for example the reason
these tech companies are all so huge
right now there's just one simple reason
the digital environment is totally
global there's no boundaries
on that and so when facebook can have a
two and a half billion people
on their platform and that was only
because there's a global
economy they're seamlessly tied into
right so but that's not because
oh that's the best way to organize
social media
is you know centralized it's just like
hey 15 years ago they started this thing
the borders were open globally they
scaled
they just kept scaling and in fact
frankly they didn't even know what hit
them they
moose grew so fast now they're like holy
[ __ ] what are we now we're the most
powerful companies in the world i mean i
think this is the thing that people
overestimate they think that all these
tech titans you know where these
wanted to take over the world no they
didn't even know what they hit them
there's just
there's like this is wild ride for them
as it is for anybody to watch this
happen
so i think it's not like that's the most
successful way to go it's that that's
the scale we're starting to work at it's
globally and so i think
it still is nimble decentralized uh
innovative um i mean all that thing is
still
better and ultimately we're gonna see
facebook and all these are gonna go the
way of you know ibm
and you know the whole thing i mean it's
like it's just gonna we're gonna watch
the cycle again
who's going to be the next updraft is it
zoom or whatever anyhow that'll be
something
but it's not because the superior thing
is oh the big centralized thing this is
it's
it's essentially this scaling thing that
we haven't really
thought through fully and we haven't
really understood
and that is going to be one of the
biggest challenges in the next 30 years
is going to be
figuring out how do we do that because
it's inevitable
that one i'll say is inevitable it's
inexorable too but it's like
by the end of the century we're going to
organize the planet on a you know
it's going to be one system it is
already one system at some level
we just haven't figured out how to do it
very well right yet uh but it's it's
gonna happen
again i'm an optimist so i'll say we'll
see
well that leads perfectly into our last
question
uh we have several questions really on
you know on growth economics growth
of everything you know we know one of
the other things the inexorables and
demographics that's going to happen in
the next um 30 to 50 years is peak
population
and we already see it as i said in the
in the developing or developed
world and we're going to see it in the
developing world
where populations are starting to go
down and so economics are
likely going to be have to start
shifting in the way that they um
that they work so i'm just wondering um
you know
do we think that there's going to need
to be different economic models i think
when you publish this story and for
instance there was a
book came out called dow 30 000 which
everyone totally ridiculed
and strangely we actually hit it in the
middle of a pandemic
um you know certainly maybe a little bit
later than that person expected but
if we did hit it and went blue right
past it in the middle of what should
have been the you know most global
economic downturn
that we've ever ever had so clearly
these things are starting to decouple
already from normal human trends and
demographics
to other things so i i just wanted to
get your thoughts on where growth leads
in the next 30
years and how that plays out in this in
this world
well okay i thought you were going to go
in a different direction that but i'll
just say two things about this which i
think is interesting so what you
mentioned is
in the 90s when we kind of projected out
to 2020
it was true uh on top of a tech boom and
an economic boom
the stock market was going to go we
didn't push it but it was clearly the
thing and in fact it happened
but here's the thing is it was again
that was a thing of again
the scaling thing it's just like people
people don't understand exponential
that's one of those actually if you
really want to get down to it is
most people don't understand what
exponential growth is and i was trying
to show in those charts about how it's
happening now and energy is happening
in in biotech and it's we we've been
happening in infotech
and so these things go from manageable
and understandable to like holy [ __ ] how
did that happen
and so i think that's kind of if you
just heard my talk here
i'm not going to be telling you oh the
stock market should collapse tomorrow
and it's all a bubble i'm actually
i'm not saying you know the current
stock market and the choices are you
know necessarily
the future but i would say there is
going to be an insane amount of wealth
to be made
in the future here and i think we're
going to watch that happen now the
critical piece of this which i thought
was that you're going to go to is
it cannot happen on the old technologies
in the old carbon energies if that
happens
we're screwed i mean we're totally
doomed honestly
but i think this is the beauty of what
the moment we're in here
is we can actually grow the entire
global economy on
clean energy sustainable everything the
way i say this is like you know
synthetic biology
packaging will be you know grown rather
than kind of plastic
and petrochemicals and anyhow all that
kind of stuff there is we know how to do
this now
now we don't know how to do everything
about it but we're past the tipping
point of understanding that
one last little thing i'll say about
this which which i um
which is a good way to think about this
which is we are so
lucky that the pandemic hit in 2020
rather than just
20 years ago in 2000 if we would have
hit 20 years ago
in 2000 the same pandemic there would
have been about
25 million 50 million americans online
and nobody else you wouldn't have these
open channel video things all over the
world you wouldn't have scientists
coordinating all
over the planet you wouldn't have kids
being able to go to school and video
everybody work from home that gone 20
years ago that's all we're taking second
thing is we wouldn't even have cracked
the first human genome we didn't even
know how to
do a genome and uh now we're following
the
you know the virus says it's mutating by
the day and it's like everybody can do
it and they share it instantaneously
that couldn't happen
uh and the same thing was uh we crashed
the global account we paused the global
economy and all the oil
industry crashed and you know everything
crashed if this had been 20 years ago
there's no way we could have scaled back
up on clean energy like solar or
wind or any of that it was so immature
it wasn't there so anyhow the point is
we're lucky it's today the triple whammy
happened today we're lucky
because we could actually do all that
amazing think what's gonna happen
another 10
20 30 years we're going to be
increasingly lucky
that oh we could solve the global
climate crisis of 2040 because holy [ __ ]
we've
everybody has ai enabled everything and
you know we got sensors all over the
planet blah blah blah anyhow there's a
bunch of ways that happens so i just
think it's a we we need to keep thinking
um
how this is possible uh and we're uh we
got to
keep our minds open our imaginations
over what could happen in the next 10 20
30 years has happened
and i think i think we're past the point
where we we now
can actually grow the global economy
robustly and still
not blow out the planet and do it on a
sustainable kind of everything plan
and uh you know it's not gonna be
perfect it's gonna be one step forward
two steps back kind of thing as we
mentioned but over time
if we have this conversation in 2050 uh
most of this will largely have played
out because this is what i'm trying to
say
nice well we want to extend the invite
for you to come back in february
of oh 2050. um to report back on the
things that
that came out as as planned and the big
surprises that
uh that hit us over though i won't do it
as long as the interval's open and you
can actually get a drink rather than
kind of
uh been sitting in a pandemic like this
but yes by that time we won't have to
worry about pandemics
yes i will do that looking forward to it
i'm also looking forward to being part
of this community in the next
25 years here 30 years to it and uh
thanks for having me here indeed well
we'll step outside and have a
have a rare interval drink outside uh
shortly after this talk so thank you so
much for joining us i really appreciate
it
appreciate it thank you and i want to
thank you our long now audience for
sticking with us during this pandemic
and during these pre-recorded talks
we'll have more coming up in the future
and thank you so much